well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive
live with me here in downing street to
see what's making the headlines uh is
the associate editor of the daily mirror
kevin mcguire and the consultant editor
of the daily mail andrew pearson lovely
to see you in person for the first time
in a very long time and here we are on
another one of those evenings it has to
be said so front pages which are a
little late tonight because of the pace
of developments over boris johnson so
let's take a look at those front pages
the eye calls the attempts by his own
colleagues to remove the prime minister
a cabinet coup
the times puts it bluntly
johnson fights for his life
not sure you've got that one
uh there it is in fact johnson fights
for his life
the metro let's have a look get exit
done boris the paper says
this is the mirror with an almost
identical headline
the financial times shows mr johnson in
the commons today saying he's been
rocked by the cabinet revolt
the guardian describes mr johnson as
desperate and deluded as he clings to
power
the liverpool echo never a fan of boris
johnson after remarks he's made about
the city and its people in the past asks
have we finally seen the back of him
this week's new statesman calls it the
last days of boris johnson why the prime
minister has no one left to lie to
while the star imagines what mr johnson
might be saying to himself tonight as
the pressure on him to quit ramps up by
the hour
so reminder by scanning the qr code you
will see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let us get the very latest thoughts
then of kevin maguire and andrew pierce
taking a look straight away at the
telegraph where we did just another
cabinet resignation andrew simon hart of
course welsh secretary a loyalist was
one of those who went into the cabinet
thinking he could persuade boris johnson
to resign uh he thought wrong because
boris johnson defies all political
gravity all political logic he is it is
part of his irrepressible energy and
charm he doesn't do things like anybody
else does he's defied them and in the
process he's also sacked one of those
who came to see him privately insulting
michael gove now that is a delicious
piece of irony it is the case of revenge
is a dish best eaten gold because of
course michael gave stabbed by boris
johnson in the front and the back in the
2016 leadership contest and it was over
in 2016 and although they've worked
closely together they've never really
trusted each other johnson's gone nuts
this is uh britain's trump here
barricade and himself in number 10 and
not wanting to come out
it's lost it's over it's finished
whatever he's doing if he's sitting
there rocking or whatever or plotting
you know it's just it's just crazy
there's no dignity to this
look i like andrew can go back the
resignation forced out of thatcher then
you remember john major lost at an
election uh follow on tony blair quit
after 10 years knew the game was up
gordon brown was out at an election
david cameron had to go he had to go
after losing the ref referendum
may was forced out by a re revolt he now
barricade and he's just it's just a
matter of time i mean this is this is
looney tunes isn't it this is looney
tunes but i don't think any of us are
surprised because he's we always a bit
we've been writing you'll have to drag
him screaming and shouting out of there
and that's exactly what's gonna happen i
think probably it will all change on
monday the 1922 committee executive
decided they're not going to change the
rules but there'll be a new executive
elected on monday and i suspect they
will then say to the prime minister if
you don't go there'll be a ballot these
are the sort of numbers against you
unless unless he says you've just
removed me as the leader of the tory
party but i'm not going to stop being
prime minister i'm just going to stay in
it i mean look i mean this technically
he could do that yeah this is crazy
crazy stuff from a crazy person yeah
well we got we got used to it
quite a tough year this year well she
can't like him can she after he you got
at her unlawfully uh prorogued
parliament so yeah there's no love lost
there but it is but this is this is
bongas this is this is the end of a
regime it's a terrible sordid tattered
end
well let's take a look at the guardian
shall we desperate deluded as he clings
to power the question is why now as far
as his allies say he has got a mandate
of 14 million people he has been put
there by the british people not by his
mps he believes it's an almost
presidential system in this country it's
not though it's the parliament
in that election yeah
and in fact actually jacob rees-mogg
said we're moving to a presidential
system in this country which of course
people like you say no we are not but
that's why he's staying he believes
because he was put there by the british
people that's not why he's staying his
state because he's a massive egotist who
thinks it's all about him and it has
been throughout his life when he was a
kid he wanted to be world king being
brazen lying refusing to accept you make
mistakes for defying reality he's got
him a long way he's got to be a number
10 and he's now trying to barricade
immense himself in that i suppose he's
going to have arcade or deliveries and
not we've not come out we'd probably see
tanks and soldiers on the streets next i
mean
this i mean come on
it is it is nonsense what johnson is
doing but you're going to hear this over
the next couple of days from a lot of
touring look he got the biggest tory
majority since 1987. margaret thatcher
was the only one to get a bit bigger
1987. so he's a he's a proven winner
he's won two london mayor it's not him
popping out oh it's the cat so the cat's
still here well the cat's fleeing that's
given up now
boris delivered that majority not the
conservative party he won it by shear
force advertising with that great phrase
get brexit done and he did okay and he
did and he got us through covered uh
he's got done well during the ukraine
war but like i said
we are in the end of days we are in the
older days
let's go back to that confidence vote
148 mps what we don't know and we'll
never know is how many people who are on
the government payroll actually voted in
that of which there are about 120 and
about a third of them have decided to
resign so the question is can he fill
those posts and if he cannot
what happens then yeah well presumably
he'll just say i'll have fewer posts in
the the frame of mind he's out there
at the moment that that's what he will
try and you'll probably see it's
streamlining leveling down rolling up or
something you know hey look he won't be
able to fill those posts but in the tea
room today there was one tory i'd be
looking at his phone waiting uh waiting
for a job offer and another tory mp said
you're you're like the plane to be the
chief stoker on the titanic after it's
hit the iceberg that this ship is
sinking it's gone who would really want
to to join it there might be some people
who will never get a job in any other
circumstances who will be prepared to do
it for a few days to get their clammy
hands on the red box their bums in a car
and a few quid in an office that's what
that's what they will do but it's over
it is over you've got to think about the
experience here of nadine to harvey this
is the most extraordinary position so
he's the chance of this checker he's
denied reports that uh if he wasn't
given the chance of a ship last night he
would have resigned last night which
could have brought the whole edifice
tumbling down so he's chance for 24
hours not even 24 hours and he goes into
number 10 but there's other ministers to
say
it's over prime minister you've got to
go but that's part of him trying to
establish this authority because he
wants to keep that job when boris
johnson has gone and i think actually
he's highly qualified
or get borrowed some suggestions he only
ever wanted to be chancellor but i mean
you know we wait and i don't know about
ambitious toys
okay paint the scene inside um downey
street for us if we look at your paper
for example just get exit done which is
a lovely play on words obviously in goes
people like nadine doris and all these
other names including simon heart the
welsh
secretary would have gone into to say
so there they are there are people there
for and against him now does he see them
individually which is what i think
margaret thatcher decided which was
everyone says a big mistake does he see
them collectively when they're more
powerful what i mean what was happening
inside there this afternoon
well you know about you better than me
sadly
i can't think why only only that only
those who really don't like him uh and
they go in and they just say he's in in
denial that's what they say he's in
total denial it just can't accept it's
gone from him uh and it's gotten a long
way and it's got on the job and he's
clinging on to it but that's what they
say now nadine doris is one of those who
won't get a job with any other prime
minister
she adores johnson because he gives her
work some of the others would get jobs
with us but i think in the concept of
part you just chat to them over the road
and they're all just fed up because
they're made to look absolute idiots and
they all fear all a large number they're
going to lose their seats if he carries
on nadine doris has been mates with
boris johnson for years and years it's
nothing to do with getting a job she was
in he was they had to go up there
joining offices when he first became an
mp and they'd been great
so the situation is they say go and he
says what no i'm not bad yeah because um
i won that mandate i had a huge mandate
that the public support me i've got
things to do i've got to talk to
president zlensky tomorrow uh i'm
getting on with the cost of living
crisis it is extraordinary of course he
lost his chance to join a cost of living
crisis big big step and those two
ministers who resigned last night would
have thought the whole edifice would
have crumbled today it didn't the world
secretary's gone decent man but one of
the more minor players in the cabinet so
if we take a look at the metro similar
headline to yours in fact it pictures
sadhu javid who made his
resignation speech after prime
minister's questions today and the word
from him was integrity in fact the word
if you look across the resignation
letters has been integrity honesty being
honorable principle now if he goes and
does this move by all those mps
mean a move towards the importance of
truth as the backbone of democracy is it
a major shift
almost away from from trumpism if i can
put it that boldly do you think well i
think at the moment you've got somebody
who's gone to an extreme and that's
that's johnson who's just lied and lied
and lied and he's now a dead man lying
he just does not know
health minister has just gone while
you're talking continues well there's
another job for somebody uh you know i
mean maybe nadine dorries can double up
or something and do do lots of them but
you'd have to see what comes after now
of course the charge from all the
opposition parties is look you lot who i
now want to get rid of him you're quite
happy to support him all the way through
party gate all the other lies all the
other disasters you've got fed up now
your rats leaving the sinking ship
because you fear you're going to lose
your seats and your jobs and you're
going to be defeated so how principled
is the move to get rid of him i mean
that's that is a i think it's a
legitimate question in british politics
now because they made a pact with a
devil when they elected him in 2019 they
knew what he was like it was always
going to end in tears this is no great
surprise
he did what he did what he was chosen to
do which is
massively he got brexit done now he's
trying to get it undone because he had
no oven ready deal as he accessed
he put a border down the irish he lied
he lied about brexit itself he won a
landslide victory and he also put page
to that appalling old marxist who is a
lot were supporting jeremy corbyn
imagine if he'd taken over the country
we'd be going to hell in a handcuff yeah
been appalling oh my god do you think we
might have worse economic growth than
anyone else
you might have got 170 000 deaths to
these ministers who are resigning now
they're thinking in very very cynical
way they don't resign now how will it
look if boris has gone in two or three
days why didn't they go and already in
our time briefly we've had two more
resignations including a cabinet member
um quick line actually on that point
from the telegraph before we see your
paper the mail which is just in
the daily telegraph can reveal that the
government whips office calculated that
mr johnson would get just 65 confidence
votes from almost 360 tory mps
number 10 insisted he would stand in a
second confidence vote if necessary so
just 65 left standing well that would be
humiliating yeah i mean absolutely
humiliating and we don't we never know
what figures graeme brady gave theresa
may when she was in exactly the same
position in 2019 but she saw the figures
it spooked her enough and she said she
was standing down and then of course she
went on for two months because it takes
two months to an elect probably a tory
leader yes and if we uh take a look at
the sun which is also in well we
discussed that very point in fact um
what would happen do you think if um
let's have a look at the sun then you'll
have to
dip your hands in blood to get rid of me
um don't quite know where that quote has
come from if it is indeed a quote but
anyway the whole point is that theresa
may lasted four and i've got the figures
in front of me
uh 1
106 days boris johnson is currently at
1078 days
he wants to beat her okay that is a big
part of this you have to remember
politicians i've got great egos and then
and it's where they're going to be in
the the pantheon of shame because
they're all going to be quite lowed down
in how long they survive but he
definitely wants to beat theresa may and
she'll be desperate that he doesn't but
it all shows it's about him and his ego
and it's not about the country it's all
about the cost of living president no no
no but but johnson just as he's lying is
like nothing we've seen before in modern
history it's just got this gigantic ego
and he
i think sachi javid got it when he he
said that look i wanted to come into
politics to do something
not to be somebody and johnson just
wanted to be somebody the older tony in
this and self-entitlement you get your
port right you want to be prime minister
but what do you do when you're you're
there now he wants to beat theresa may
well there's no way to run a country
when he got big problems in public
services and the economy is in serious
trouble partly because of the policies
of his government but not entirely we've
only got them in the left just want to
see the times and uh the inside pages of
the time we saw a flash of it there as
well uh johnson fights for his life as
you can see there he is at uh pmq's and
the inside pages go stacked by phone as
a stream of ministers tell johnson to
quit and we understood that michael gove
was the man who was helping boris
johnson prepare for pmq's i'm sure he
was the headline on the front of the
times is interesting but that could have
been written this morning frankly
because he was fighting for his life
last night he's still fighting for his
life he's going to lose
but he fights on mrs thatcher fame she
said when she came out of number 10 when
she'd come back from paris after that
signing that treaty and she hadn't done
a well enough in the first round of the
toy legion hazelton she said i fight on
i fight to win she was gone the next
year but she left with some dignity she
did johnson is going to leave with zero
dignity he is gonna have to be gonna
make a fight
and screaming uh they may have to get
men in flapping white courts to tear
them out he's got it he's got a career
to uh to fall back on which is
journalism of course oh god what are you
writing i'm writing about that
right well
that's the point he's caused enough harm
to our trade in the past were these she
was it 275 000 pound chicken feed he
called it the telegraph i don't think
he'll employ him again kevin mcguire
still a fan as you can hear